olivia rodrigo still isn't used to all
the attention surrounding her
and her love life saying it's been
really hard
and really weird there's lots of things
going on in them
yeah i'm just like jittering in a new
interview for the september issue of gq
the 18 year old pop star admits that she
tries to stay off social media as much
as she can
and tries to stay oblivious to the
public's opinion of her personal life
just a little refresher olivia's love
life became a topic of conversation
after the release of her debut single
driver's license
[Music]
the hit track is thought to be about her
rumored breakup with her high school
musical the musical the series co-star
joshua bassett
and his supposed new flame sabrina
carpenter
though neither party ever confirmed they
were ever together
olivia's amazing the singer tells gq
quote
it was really hard for me to watch
people on tick-tock and stuff that
dissects my 17-year-old love life
that was really weird but again i think
i understood the curiosity
it doesn't affect me it doesn't matter
it doesn't affect my songwriting and my
life
olivia adds that any insecurity or fear
over public opinion
can be avoided by simply staying off
social media
an activity she only allows herself to
do 30 minutes a day
it helps me not to look at that you're
literally not meant to know what
everyone is saying about you
at all times olivia adds that she
learned early the importance of
separating
person and persona quote when people who
don't know me are criticizing me
they're criticizing my persona not my
person
but that's really difficult though too
because my persona is being as genuine
and honest as i possibly can
so it's this weird dichotomy oh god
immensely
immensely as for the current state of
her love life
olivia says that she briefly gave dating
apps a go
but it was quote so vomit adding quote
like i could not yeah i mean
it's just crazy i'm so happy for the
first time
in so long i just don't want to talk
with it i just love my girlfriends and
love my job
and am exactly where i've always wanted
to be
although just days after her gq
interview the teen was spotted
displaying some pda with 24 year old
producer adam fayes in la
the two first sparked romance rumors
when they attended the space jam a new
legacy premiere party at six flags magic
mountain together
in june so chatter over her love life
probably won't stop swirling anytime
soon and we can only hope it inspires
more bops
so when you're gonna tell her
that we did that too she thinks it's
special
but it's already used that was our place
i found it first i
made the jokes you tell to her when
she's with you
[Music]
do you get deja